so during the class I usually do a
little boat and the physical situation
we are interested the to proceed will be
the outcome of the of the calculation I
think that is actually very very
interesting things to do first of all
Dow will attract the attention of the
students that we are going to do a
prediction of a physical situation okay
so that that's actually the first
purpose to encourage participation of
the students into class and the secondly
I can know if the majority of the
students already know the outcome or not
by looking at the boat result so if I
have if I have my polarizer arranged in
this direction can you predict what will
happen to the readout on the scope where
I see signal or not how many help you as
you think we will see signal if I
arrange that the the the electromagnetic
wave is she pointing polarized in the up
and down okay one okay on these four
people think so
how many of you think nothing was
nothing over change Nancy I'm sorry not
nothing will be observed by them
let's go okay most of you as you think
so so that's actually really 2d his
experiment I choose to use an analog
master instead of clicker and over or
the poor with utter take taking called
course and that is because I would like
this process to be a smooth side I I
could achieve so it doing it by raising
your hand first of all they they have to
do a lot more by raising your hand
instead of clicking a button so that's
actually makes a difference for then to
focus on my question okay so secondly I
don't want to do automatically country
because usually they provide a graph and
I have to
switch back and forth between graf and
my lectures or other lecture slides and
la usually takes some time and also that
introduced in turn into any
interruptions during my lecture